there's the interviewer let case study
format in the interview we let case
study format so how do these two formats
distinguish themselves in the
interviewer-led format the interviewer
will lead the whole conversation he will
guide you through the case study and
here we go question by question he will
present a little part of such a more
complex business problem and he will
expect you now to come up with an answer
to come up with a solution to this part
and once you had a bit of a discussion
about this specific part you might
completely change the topic to another
aspect of the Soul case study and then
it will go into the details about this
new part of you so this is now a format
when you are much more on the receiving
end you're not supposed to Now guide the
interviewer from this case study but
it's rather you answering questions that
you will get on a specific business
problem